snapchat here some people have to
understand I predict
I'm going to hardcore here I predict in
2016 that snapchat will have a number
one two or three spot in the most
important apps in the world from the 13
to 40 let me say it again 40 year old
sector maybe even 45 of 50 I'm that the
25 to 50 year old sector on snapchat in
2016 is gonna blow away the far majority
of people who are watching this episode
and so let me give you a fun fact on how
to get good at it or start playing with
it the one big creative play that I see
on snapchat that makes it so different
is the notion of taking a picture and
then drawing on top of it someone do you
follow me I've seen things the weird
spider or the raindrops I've started
play with it a little bit I'm a big fan
of that it opens up enormous creativity
enormous Cody run some of my funny snaps
I don't know where you're putting them
do you rock but and so I'll give you
those images yeah so if your winery take
pictures in the wine room in the
vineyard of the bottle and then draw
creative things around it I do think
that people will enjoy that it'll be a
hell little haha you can do some little
contests by running in I think drawing
on top of the images because the images
on Instagram and Facebook and Twitter
they all look the same this drawing
thing is a real creative variable it is
a difference maker the attentions on
snapchat
I am bullish on that Ghost